[Music]  last week president george w bush's  paintings went on display at the George  W Bush Presidential Library that's right  now critics are divided about how good  they are here's Bush's portrait of  Vladimir Putin next to a photo of Putin  I think it's so bad  here's his portrait of Hamid Karzai  which I thought was not bad also pretty  good here's his portrait of German  Chancellor Angela Merkel not bad now you  know President Bill Clinton's also been  painting and he has a contrasting style  too Bush here's Clinton's painting of  Angela Merkel I thought was it  here's Clem's portrait of House Minority  Leader Nancy Pelosi finally here's  President Clinton as he sees himself I  think that was really  [Applause]  [Music]